i'm coming with sally babes we're
continuing babe fest 2021
exactly babe so true chrissy this is so
much fun hanging out in the hotel room
with you anyway babe fest is continuing
so get your tickets we got friday
october 29th in durham north carolina
that has been on sale that is going to
sell out you get those tickets right
away sunday december 26 will be in grand
prairie texas aka close to dallas monday
the 27th of december we are in san
antonio texas
the stars at night are big and bright
deep in the heart
continue with texas tuesday december
28th we will be in sugarland texas which
is near houston wednesday december 29th
st louis missouri thursday december 30th
in columbus ohio and new year's eve 2021
into 2022 join us friday december 31st
in cincinnati
january 1st i won't have a home he's a
pig don't see him
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey
[Music]
you know what you feel better today yeah
last week i was in the mood
now
and now you're back back sally you know
what's wrong lay down sally no don't
mean to be so cruel i've been trying all
night long just to talk to you you know
that lay it down sally not bad sally's
no
so this episode this episode's gonna be
um a little bit of a shortened one just
because i gotta go i gotta go pick up
the kids babe there's a day today we
gotta pick up the kids we got soccer
then we gotta we go to bocce's i i heard
yeah and i'm saying this can i say this
can i talk freely say it you're you've
been invited to uh what is it my next
next-door neighbor so we just met
surprise birthday party yeah i would not
go to that you would just say no
you you i mean it's an it's a big it's
very kind of them
i love that you're being graciated into
the neighborhood they're putting out
like that's very nice of them i don't
know these people though you don't even
you don't know them they invited you no
no but i'm saying i don't know right but
that's what i'm saying like for me for
me it's a little fast and i wouldn't i
wouldn't want to have that obligation on
my plate like you have to go now to a
restaurant for the
birth for the party of a child with a
full group of people that you have no
idea no you're gonna go there and no
it's not the party of a child it's the
party of the adults oh i thought that
the children's birthday no the
children's the children our children oh
our friends and get on the bus together
the adults what's the party it's a
surprise like birthday party for the
adult for the mom but you're gonna yell
surprise you don't know her i we don't
know anybody there no i know who they
are i know who they are you know what's
so funny there's a video for me i would
have bobbed and weaved out of that yeah
no i wanted to but i think
i think jasmine wants to get out of the
house
because i said that immediately i said i
i like them they're very very nice
people we love it but i was like i don't
know any of their
family friends i don't know yeah anybody
it's a tough sell for me yeah we're
going to bocce's nice yeah which is
great food but she told me jasmine told
me she goes i'm going to i want to give
her a staten island i love santa shout
out
shout out forrest i love it um and and
she said we're going with the kids
no the kid no we got a babysitter wow
big night out
out i'm gonna wear my night by the way
these nike pants these are nike pants
these are my new lulu's
do
no but these are sweatpants feel these
these are my airport pants and my fat
pants these are them here i feel that
that's the so that's the same yeah but
here this is the new yeah
are
100 for pants but again i tested them
seem like they're far proof and shrink
proof in the wash which is all i care
about i don't want my clothes to shrink
in the wash they hit it for 100 on those
they hit me so with these right i was
looking for
i was looking for an elevated sweatpant
a couple years back
an esp elevated sweatpants yeah and i'm
like all right i really want these nike
ones i keep seeing her i love the way
they look and everything so i was like i
went to the nike like flagship store in
the city like five floors i go in there
and i i go can you give me those tapered
sweatpants yeah so they show me my tur i
put them on i really love them i get to
the red shirt i didn't look at the price
okay okay it was an embarrassing stitch
get to the register two pairs of pants
black and gray they bring them up
one take a guess
250
the pants were
424
the pants were fought one pair of paper
twelve each
is that what you do in season ten and
practical jokers
because we didn't i said i said uh you
made a mistake what i was like no no no
i go no no i just got it it's just the
two sweats they go yeah yeah
are these where are the two hundred and
twelve dollars these are them yeah i
mean i've had them for three four years
i was gonna say are they worth though
how could any how could any pampy work
that
put it on my like my you know because i
get to get wardrobe for work a little
bit so and i can write that off because
it is an expense that i need to do yeah
so i just swallowed my product i said
what could what could be so good about
these 212 so
i didn't know what to do i asked them
what their return policy was so i said
i'll bring him home so i don't look
embarrassed i'll try him on i'll decide
later i tried him on i really liked him
and i was like i i can't spend this kind
of money but
i see everyone i just i just i said i
freaking and then after a while they
started to pill
you understand what does pill mean you
know when you get like that like all the
fuzz gets like loose
up on you and they sell that they sell a
tool yeah you could you could yeah it's
like a gun and you like go over it
you know yeah
killing is the thing so i was like these
things look you kind of see it like it
started
and now i hit them with the thing so i
take the pilling off but i was like it
started to pill right away and i was
like this can't be for a pair of pants
like this so i didn't know what to do so
i took a picture of the pilling and i
tweeted nike
because i was like oh i'll just ask and
i was like hey i just got these they're
like your new latest and greatest very
expensive pants and yeah look at all
this i was like is there anything we
could do about that and they just like
publicly were like nah they they tweeted
back at you now yeah no way we can't i
said can you replace these can you give
me my money back or whatever and they
just literally just were like nope like
like it was like nah interesting yeah
and it seems like you tweeted them often
this is a different tweet yeah oh wow
hey from
hey at nike store my custom shoes i've
only wore a few times are ripping off of
the sole can someone help me replace
when was that four years ago four and a
half years remember tweeting this no but
i i do remember now that i'm looking at
it like uh i made a pair of shoes custom
and they they literally just ripped a
hole ripped open so i don't know who to
you know you call the uh store
those kids then i can help you i don't
know what the hell they're yeah and i
also have the custom shoes you order
online they're like nike id right so i
ordered them online so like i didn't
know i wasn't going to like
i mean it was all truly ripping off of
them yeah i sent the picture they sent
me a new pair can i put on your hat and
glasses you you can you must
i just want it it's like a version like
i've kind of there's a
i would say
vision's not that bad let me see your
glasses please before you put that on
wow
what do we think you look like uh
yeah you look like an office manager
right
you look it you're on the third thing by
the way i'm gonna i just know for sure
i'm gonna have to move to seconds
normally launch head
oh my god
you won the last dot of the hat yeah the
last sizing dot of the hat is what you
just put it on
wow
you look so funny you look like a
hipster
in 2012 people who study found people
wear glasses are actually more
intelligent researchers conjecture that
the eyeglasses wearers are less likely
to partake in outdoor activities perhaps
for fear of damaging their fragile
glasses that's interesting i never
thought about you
you were able to read that through the
glasses yeah does that mean i can't see
do you need glasses
if i'm seeing things clearer now
2020 is your vision
i thought it was let me see
i can't you in the hat wow this is
killing me there's a glitch when i go
like this
there's a glare i can read it but it
looks different then when i go like this
it looks clearer
i i i'm having a hard time i'm actually
what do you think of this
i think we should give him an eye test
let's see if we can get one i'll do an
eye test let me see look at me
that hat is what do you guys think do
you wear hats never wear hats because no
fats hit no hats fit my head my fat head
i wear fat
i'm on three also because i have all his
hair but when i'm not on three but i
don't particularly have a small head
no but you're three normally i'm a two
two or three okay here we go
you know what they told me i have an
astigmatism in each eye and astigmatism
is when i'm told that your eyeball which
should be round or oval looks like a
football yeah and and i didn't know i
had any and then when i went in for
glasses like eight nine ten years or
whatever it was the guy's like yeah you
have an astigmatism in both eyes wow and
he's like you should have had glasses
since you were a child really yeah but
you got speaking of stigma because i'm
at like 35. speaking of stigmatism
you ever seen that movie stick mata
yes scary movie that's a real thing she
knows what the second mod is
it's people it happens it's a real
phenomenon i don't want you to hurt your
eyes are you sure you're okay having
those on i feel great right now
excellent stigmata is when you get all
of a sudden these people out of nowhere
get holes in their hands and feet is it
real is dig moder real is the movie real
or is it the same as the moon landing
[Laughter]
there is no medical scientific
explanation if stigmata is real
yeah i need to know if that's real i
mean it's pretty sick if it's real well
you just get the holes in your hands and
get your surprise holes in your hands
and your feet so it's not real
it could be i'm gonna go just the hat
and see how this one yeah yeah but i do
love the glasses yeah do i have to put
the glasses on that napkin no you just
put them down so what's the napkin for
um in case it gets smudged okay
it's really not a napkin what is it it's
a handkerchief glass cleaner well it
seems stigma is not real but something
that is real that me and chris talked
about that's interesting is the the
people with the past lives if you want
to tell sal about that
so i don't know if we've spoken about
this on hey babe
have you ever well we did speak i know
we spoke about this on the road maybe
even before we started this podcast yeah
remember being in the back of a car with
you going i forgot where we were going
maybe nashville um
and
i talked to you about the show the ghost
inside my child okay you remember this
or you don't not really okay so the
ghost inside my child
is a show
where
r reality show
i love you with this man i love you with
this add-on
it changes like ever your words change a
little bit even though you're speaking
the same the image of you is very very
entertaining to me you like this yeah
it's so like it's so
naughty you want to go with it it's so
not you
it's so funny to me like i had good
should i try to see it you look uh
boyishly playful and charming should i
turn it around and go with a different
look on it or do you want me to go full
i say keep this look the full rest of
the show yeah okay yeah so ghost inside
my child is a show about
children legitimate real not actors or
actresses okay
not even ones that play actors and
actors on tv i'm talking about real
reality
people yeah okay
that
have the ghost of someone who died
inside their body and can recall
memories and speak different languages
as if they're that person okay yeah i
think i do remember this now because did
you show me a clip where a kid just
started speaking another language or
something ripping it in german
out of nowhere that's that's insane
right that has to be uh a brain glitch
right yes but it's start but a brain
glitch if they can completely recall
someone else's memories
yeah how do you speak fluent german well
because because
the thing is is is i watched this uh an
interview from a guy who like did a lot
of like dmt stuff on on he was on joe
rogan i forgot his name but it was
interesting he said what he believes and
again this is just people doing things
but what he believes is what really
reality is and what all this is it's
just like one big like cosmic still
where like i'm not you you're not me
you're not you like we're all just
together we're all just in it together
yeah so when you think of it that way if
we're just all matter and molecules
together then it makes sense it's like
somebody's memories just got put in
somebody else's brain like you said just
like a cosmic glitch but it when you see
this you're like okay
how there's no way that that could be
true there's no way that that is this
gonna freak me out what clip is this is
it the clip we watched on the chrissy
chaos
this clip is there another clip or you
think this is a good clip this one's
short let's do this clip yeah this is a
freaky freaking clip
freaky sound i don't know if i'm ready
to suck your balls in
kate was very good at it
toughness calm quiet right about the
time kade was three he would wake up
screaming about folly molly kate's mom
has got a
standard
he began drawing um it would start off
with things like lightning
two buildings
man falling off
in my head at the time
i did begin to
think he was describing 911. well
i got news for you pause it for a second
what we found out we're going to get to
the rest of it but it just hit me
kade is osama bin laden go
as a mother
i was concerned about the fact that so
early on he was obsessed with death
dying but he would always assure me that
we don't die
he would
constantly tell me we don't die and that
he picked me
he would tell me that he chose me he
would tell me he was older than i hold
on
this is this oh it's over
i mean
is it terri do you have chills yeah it's
terrifying i can't watch a show like
this
dude look at kate so cuz it's so
chilling and then he's just like he's a
little kid on the bio
just a little cute kid from 2014 this is
just a little cute kid on a bike
literally i ghost inside my childhood
premiered i guess on the lmn network i
watch the show you can watch both
seasons of it on youtube it is i can't
if i was alone in the house with pure
daylight as it is right now i could not
watch this alone i would be terrified
yeah i mean well if you're the mom and
your kids all of a sudden like we don't
die i chose you i i
i my kids started talking like that i
don't know what i would do
i don't know what i would do no no i i
can't i don't know what the hell i do
either i don't know what i would do
because because i i would be freaked out
to stay with them
but i observed my child but i'm not
going to just give them give them up let
me ask you this it's pure daylight right
now it's it's noon right now whatever
time it is
it's
it's
we're in your studio if me and pimp left
and put on the ghost inside my child and
left the apartment put in the ghosts on
my child would you be scared to walk
downstairs to get out the front door of
the studio by yourself in pure daylight
i do i would i get scared like that i
can't i can get freaked out like that
like when i'm in hotels sometimes
alone in a hotel and i got my mind
racing i really do i felt that i've been
in haunted hotels before oh no i know i
have yeah you know you have too right oh
yeah i mean especially in the middle of
the country it's like is this a burial
ground what's going on yeah yeah there's
been nights where like i i
i shut everything off and then i was too
freaked out so i put the tv on to go to
bed and then i was still freaked out i
don't know what was going on in my head
but i just felt something didn't add up
and then i had to go i had to sleep with
the with the lights on yeah
when we go on the road can we please
stay in the shining hotel that's in
maine right
i was supposed to go to a wedding there
and they got because of the colorado
yeah the stanley hotel stanley yeah well
yeah we can go i think it's that one
room that they filmed in or whatever
yeah this is what the shining is based
on or where they film the shining or
both i think it's what it's based on
what it's based on yeah i actually
watched like a ghost hunter thing do
there i'd love this place is creepy as
hell yeah yeah we should also stay in
the clown motel you ever see that no no
what is that
oh man that might be fun i would do that
at the clown what city is that in let's
do a show near it
the world famous clown motel tanopa
nevada
what is it what is it tanopa
oh my god i like that it's a motel
because the clown hotel is a little too
classy i like that it's a motel but i am
weary of motel oh that looks fun look at
that room
that's the clown motel
wait so let me ask you a question real
quick did you say when you go to sleep
in a hotel room you typically sleep with
all the lights and tv and everything off
typically
uh typically i'll sh i'll probably fall
asleep to the tv and then wake up
somewhere and shut it at some point see
i never i have never once in my life
been alone in the hotel room and slept
with all the lights and things off in
the middle of the night there have been
times when i've woken up at 7 30 in the
morning
and then went to the bathroom and then
turned the tv off and can sleep at
daylight right but at the the very least
i'm going to turn the tv off i at least
have to have the bathroom light on or a
hallway light on i have never i i don't
think i've ever been by myself and slept
in complete darkness if i'm sleeping
with someone or someone's in the house
then i can do it but i i would say if
i've slept whatever ten thousand nights
nine thousand and nine hundred and
ninety seven of them have had some time
yeah yeah i used to beg my mom to leave
the hallway line on when i was a kid
after i saw freddy krueger right yeah
for years for years you know what i used
to do man i used to suffer i don't know
if i ever mentioned this before but i
was so scared and there was nothing she
could really do about it and the thing
about freddy krueger is that son of a
[ __ ] comes back in your dreams
so that's where he gets on when you go
to sleep you know what i mean like you
fall asleep and that's when he gets you
so after i saw that i was like does not
compute because i'd be laying in bed
just like this just like i will not fall
asleep and i started to not sleep after
i saw that like i would i would i would
i would i wouldn't fall asleep until my
body physically shut down and i couldn't
hold it anymore otherwise i would just
lay there with my eyes open and i would
beg to leave the whole light on and she
would and that was very helpful but
sometimes she wouldn't like she was like
oh you got to get over this you know and
she would shut it but what i would do
also is i would get
for some reason i was like if i'm fully
under the blanket i probably have some
layer of protection so i'm talking about
i was like i mean i was like i don't
know 10 whatever it wasn't i would take
the blanket and put it 100
and tuck it around my whole body like i
was in a sarcophagus right and i would
sleep
with the blanket one like almost like
the the blanket was aluminum foil and i
wrapped myself in it right and i like
you a chicken cutlet and i would i would
leave maybe maybe a hole this big right
by here to like suck to suck
and i would get drenched drenched yeah
so when i woke up in the morning i would
open the thing and my blanket sheets
mattress would drenched in sweat because
i dare not
lift that back up in the middle of night
that happened for like a year yeah yeah
wow yeah and my mom would like
i don't know i don't recall she even
knew because she would probably like
don't do that but i i it was the only
way i could sleep only wake and but now
you don't need to do that no but i'm not
i'm not exaggerating by the way it was
the only way i could sleep and i did it
every night and my bed was like my
sheets she had to throw them out
eventually because it was like dripping
and sweating yeah and you didn't even
have the sleep apnea mask on what sleep
apnea
could you have done that if you had the
sleep apnea mask on
at that time because i do that i do it
now
i'm saying no but would you be able to
sweat and sleep like a tinfoil burrito
with the sleep apnea mask i do it now
you do oh you're right you still have
the mask you have the mask on and you
still have the blanket i do this thing
where i put like my head in between two
pillows like a sandwich right but the
pillow the pillows are very very heavy
right and it's awesome
whatever uh not those but another one
yeah yeah and so they create this like
they they create like a
pitch black and no sound for me
so it's like almost like a sensory
deprivation thing but since i had the
seat back mask on i could breathe right
so i just crushed my head two weighted
you know like a weighted blanket sure
it's like a weighted like like i don't
think i like the pillow feels weighted
too it's very soothing yeah yeah yeah
the only time i've slept like you
described was i was like 27 or 25 on the
queen mary i don't know if you've ever
stayed there oh yeah the [ __ ] a haunted
ship yeah it was creeping me out didn't
you go there like film a rapper
concerned a bunch of rappers but i
stayed on the queen mary
and why would you you booked
accommodations at the queen mary yeah
oh it's just docked and it's like a land
hotel that's docked yep and and they
have all the like even the daycare
center that they used to use is still
there with all the toys from like the
1800s is it nice it looks like a contact
with those three you're literally
sleeping in an old room that somebody
would stay on while it was shipping
around so it's small and like not
comfortable not at all so do you stay
there for just to say i stayed there it
was it was supposed to be the one of the
most haunted hotels in america and did
you feel like it was haunted oh yeah i
was creeped out i felt like everything
was watching me really so like when you
walked to your room i was like the one
time at a ghost thing when like all
right i'm freaking like you had to walk
down a hallway but with all your
equipment camera equipment and stuff oh
my god that must have been a nightmare
for you it was it was jesus and then
like they have all the instruments all
the people used to like eat with like
everything everyone use is just sitting
there still
it's the creepiest so the rap concert
you filmed they weren't staying there
you just decided to do the rap concert
took place not even a quarter mile from
the ship the ships in the background all
the photos
it looks like you can't even go anywhere
the queen mary looks like it's stationed
there
is that rock or there's like rocks
around it like it couldn't even if it
wanted to couldn't leave oh no no no
you're not leaving it's more like the
things that haven't left the ship that
creep you out wow have you heard of it
before sal yeah because queen mary was
not the biggest ship at one point yeah
yeah or the queen mary 2 whatever it is
dude you know what you know you know
pimp's been at my house before you still
got to come over but i have like a you
know a staircase like right in the
middle of my house like you know
whatever get to the top floor we don't
get a freaking elevator we're not going
to you know we're not going to rappel up
and down so yeah so we have a staircase
now you need stairs
which you know whatever i don't think
our kids kids might need stairs but
right now we need stairs my friend has a
fl uh ranch house one floor still has
desks sometimes just knew him somebody
just want to go up and down
so
i mean you want to talk about terrifying
so first of all i don't even understand
how like little kids minds work so we
used to live in an apartment and you
know i have a six-year-old daughter so
she would be like freaked out like about
anything in a little apartment right
yeah so when we first moved into the
house we were like oh she's going to be
terrified like a big house but not she
never said anything she's like going to
sleep whatever whatever
i woke up
two
uh three nights ago like i don't know
three o'clock in the morning something
like the middle of the night pitch black
and i woke up because i wanted to go
downstairs and get a glass of water i'm
at the top of my stairs and i turn on
the light at i could turn on the light
switch at the top of my stairs to go put
on the lights downstairs i turn on the
light of the top my stairs and
my daughter delilah is standing with her
piggy and hello i swear to god and a
small glass of water look at me and she
goes hey dad
no no no no no no no no no
i swear
i woke up my little daughter and jasmine
and they were like what is going on she
was standing there was a piggy and
blankie she had went downstairs by
herself into where she wouldn't even the
balls on this child come out of
that's yes the ball's on my daughter the
the which i mean i've been waiting to
show you guys and we're really happy
about it so she so she
literally went downstairs into the on
her own accord on her own accord didn't
tell anyone took her piggy and blank he
turned on the light by herself filled up
water from the fridge i didn't even know
she could reach filled up but she can
filled up water from the fridge and was
coming back up the stairs when i turned
on the water and saw it and as luck
would have it she was looking up at me
when i turned the line it was the most
terrifying experience of my life i
almost fell off my my staircase holy cow
wow and she just went down on her own
she wasn't scared or anything didn't
even wake us up
i think that they're not scared until
they
some that we give their consciousness a
reason to be scared we don't show any
scary movies so like we don't do
anything you said she'd be scared in the
apartment that's what i'm saying it
doesn't make sense she was scared
crapless in the apartment and it was a
mini apartment right well she wouldn't
even leave her room if we didn't have
the hallway maybe thinking because of
the hallway like you were saying with
your mom do you feel um i'm scared in
that house i was gonna say like are you
creeped out in the house a little bit
i've only had one night where i felt
creeped out why why would you feel crazy
so one night i just i couldn't fall
asleep and i kept having like weird
dreams it just creeped me and something
creeped me out but it wasn't necessarily
the housekeeping no it could have just
been my stupid brain you don't hear any
noises or get like a ghost vibe do you
feel like it's your home yet do you feel
like oh this is my safe like this is my
sanctuary um it's starting to feel like
that we still got some boxes that aren't
unpacked but it's starting it's starting
to feel like when you walk around though
there's a sense of familiarity like do
you feel like you've in inhabited it in
a way that you feel like comfort like
this is like this is familiar this is
this is home this um actually no i would
say no it's a little time it still takes
a little time like no like i still think
i'm going to fall down the stairs i
still right i still like think like when
you're walking around the house you
still like this is my house i can't
believe it's my house yes and no there's
certain times i'm like this is my house
and there's certain times they're like
oh did i pay for this airbnb you don't
like right so there's certain you know
what happened to me too yesterday i
forgot i came just things that happened
i forgot it's not that big of a deal but
it was just funny i literally didn't
know
i didn't know that the construction
there's construction workers still doing
our house in our living room and you can
walk in our living room you can if you
walk like you can walk to the bathroom
and shower on like um like a little
balcony thing that we have in our living
room right so i didn't know that anybody
was there i thought you know my daughter
was sleeping i thought jasmine was in
our room and i walked completely 100
butt naked across the living room floor
into my bathroom and both construction
workers who don't
[Laughter]
and then jasmine told me they were
laughing and talking about in spanish
and i was like oh my god
dude so yeah um i think you're like i
woke up in the middle of night my
construction worker was thinking
dude halloween's coming up when is it is
halloween when is halloween october 31st
notice
ryan's october 31st this year it's just
october i think it's a monday yeah
because it's a leap year it's on october
31st yeah yeah
um so this year i made a pack to
celebrate it again yeah yeah i talked to
somebody last night actually what are
you gonna pick um i don't know what i'm
gonna be yet but i have not really
celebrated halloween for years now and
it's time to turn that around when you
say not celebrating you mean haven't put
on a costume or like haven't done any
like what do you mean by selling
both no i just like you know what it is
like i used to love halloween i used to
look forward to halloween i used to
enjoy all the fruits of halloween and
then like i one year i got busy one year
i couldn't decide one year i wasn't in
the mood and what i'm like
i don't have a costume i can't think of
nothing good and i just let it go for
years right i didn't participate i
didn't go to any parties i didn't go you
know halloween parade the parade i did
eight years in a row i used to i told
you this oh no the parade i used to
organize afraid in new york city yeah so
when i ran the bar i used to organize
this party where like everyone would
meet at the bar to pre-game one okay
and i would organize i would
pick the costume for everyone we wear
matching costumes okay so usually be
anywhere between like it is was as
little as four people and as many as
like i think uh 19 people and you pick
costumes out one year for 19 people yeah
no no not individually so what i would
do is this year we're all gumbies this
year we're all chickens this year we
were bunnies chickens
gumbies
stay puft marshmallow men
gingerbread men
skeletons
you know things like that right
apes pink hot pink apes but the whole
thing would be anonymous right so they
have a sign up sheet at the bar
and then we they come we pre-game there
i i'd order everybody's costume and then
we'd show up everybody would be like 19
gumbies right and then we'd get on the
boat and we go and the village parade
which is the biggest halloween parade in
the country a million people come watch
that thing anyone's allowed in it
what do you mean you're allowed to be in
it you can just walk out as long as you
go to the spring street entrance at like
i think it's like seven o'clock and you
just wait your turn crowds like
bottleneck there and then they let you
someone's there and like go ahead go and
you can walk the whole thing from spring
to like 20th street so you've done i did
it eight years in a row when i found out
that that you could do that i was like
i've never been to a brand i've never
seen a prank can you do it this year
with coven and all that stuff can you
it's outdoors i don't see why you
couldn't and they didn't have it last
year because of covid this year they're
having it some guy
some guy donated a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars just to save the parade
because the parade was not going to
happen but it's also wild because
people are going nuts
it's people are playing live music
instruments there's parties in every
single bar and business you pass and
everyone that lives there are throwing
rooftop parties and terrorist parties so
it's like mardi gras and then everyone
there's all these crazy floats there's
people on stilts there's demon people
there's always on october 31st always on
it's not like the weekend of it is on
the day always on the day and
it's it's like anything goes like people
are all like just it's it's you want to
do it this year massive street park
yes i told we were talking to people
yesterday i really got a little crew
form and we all go and then you're
anonymous too so you're going to do the
thing with the costumes yes
so you shall join you should yeah yeah
because i want to go because if it's on
a sunday if october because we got big
halloween plans with my family uh
october 30th we're going to be doing
something so we're going to do the
trick-or-treating and the big thing on
sunday on saturday yeah but you could
still do the trick or treating on the
day of in the daytime as long as we get
there you got to get there like six i
got to look at the deal listen
can we get involved in this yeah 100
okay
i want to go do this yeah yeah yeah so
what's the cost so what are we going to
do so like every two yeah i'll get it i
got i'm working on that right now i'm
working with what i'd like to do well
i'm in i'm not going to say the costume
no because i don't want people to know
who i am we're in we're in yeah okay but
uh because i'm going to say with taxes
yeah here's all of us in gowns could you
imagine we're on the table like the
whole thing is we cover our face
so that we can just like i don't know
it's like it's just more fun that way
when people are like what is this sea of
gumbys like when you don't see a face
like we always get on the news do you
have an idea of what you want the
costume to be someone floated an idea
that i think is pretty good i'm i'm
doing my do deal on it okay okay we
should go because that's show squid game
is we should go with squid game
oh you know so three people have told me
to watch squid game no no no
i turned i turned on last night and then
i saw what you're saying
like 10 seconds the first 10 seconds of
you know how you turn on netflix and it
automatically goes into the trailer i
didn't want to i didn't want i like to
not know what things are about
especially when it's the hot new [ __ ]
yeah so i just jumped off but i saw
those pink outfits dude squid game uh i
i can't stop watching it tonight you
love it i personally would start
watching it i
i start watching it now on the podcast
wow
i don't even know what it's about
uh to be honest with you i saw all nine
episodes and i don't know what it's
about but i know that it was the most re
i could not
stop watching it it's so good but you
don't understand it no you understand it
you understand it's just
subtitles or you could do dubs
you could you could do voice dubs you
could choose you could choose that yeah
that's an option you could rely on dubs
by your choice 100 netflix gives you the
option oh i didn't know that 100 percent
oh yeah because the trailer they were
speaking english that's why i didn't
understand it no i i'm so by the way i'm
a guy who i have subtitles on
24. i never i never i can't watch
anything without the sub two four seven
three six five same same last night i
watched the new movie the the guilty
yeah i showed the guilty with jake
thought
[Laughter]
yeah isn't it jim hall gyllenhaal right
yeah the ending i liked wait you saw it
i thought it came out with didn't yeah
but i saw it oh okay it's about recently
you saw her recently yeah jkg yeah did
you see it the whole thing i watched it
last night what'd you think i loved it
jake's gentle just i mean he stays in
[ __ ] i mean the kid is in chat jake
gyllenhaal is arguably my favorite actor
of this generation the what he the
performance in the guilty was fantastic
he's riveting riveting can't take my
eyes off the boy riveting and and it's a
good it's an interesting movie because
the writer from true detective and then
the the the director from training day
yeah and jake gyllenhaal we were
flipping last night and i was like
gyllenhaal trudeau i was like this is a
this is a no-brainer you know the voice
that you never see him is ethan hawk
the guy he's talked to on the phone the
whole movie is ethan hawk i did not know
that ethan hawk and he's just never
trying to guess who that was but i heard
burr's voice
is burr in it yeah burr has bird has is
one of the voices really yeah and and
she was like i think that's burr and i'm
like i know it when is that i was
thinking the same thing and then at the
end he's in the credits when is he in it
he's um he's one of the callers
that calls and is like yelling at him
about like a 9-1-1 call or whatever but
it's not it's pretty it's like it's like
10 15 20 lines like it's a whole thing i
forget what the moment what it was it's
a whole scene is it the guy who was the
prostitute in this car
yes that's bill burke i think it is yeah
yeah i think that's right
yeah that's hilarious maybe maybe
it could be i i forget it's a good one i
was i was also
on the sativia yeah yeah
sativia it's 157. it's 157 okay so i got
why don't we do this why don't we do
this why don't i
i have to go pick up the kids because i
have the day but why don't you guys you
want why don't you keep going just you
and pimp
i mean we could just wait and have
deroza right for
a little bit
as a guest star on on hb fills in for
the last why not fills into the list
there yeah that's fun he'll should be
our name i didn't ask him what time he
was coming did you no i didn't [ __ ] no
he's coming he's derose is coming like 2
30.
you sure about that
um all right well listen yeah so i gotta
go pick up the kids but um well i gotta
go i gotta go pick up the kids and then
i'm going right to uh durham north
carolina on october 29th
guys what's up babes we're here to talk
to you about mint mobile which pimpy you
started using recently right this is a
cool thing have you ever heard of a
cellular service that sells the service
not the phone that's what mint mobile
does uh it's just 15 bucks a month
that's a secret sauce they're the first
company to sell wireless service online
only by cutting out the retail stores
there's no overhead cost and the savings
get passed on to you um
yeah people looking for extra savings
mobile offers premium wireless for just
15 a month that is
buck wild okay all plans come with
unlimited talk and text and high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network you can use your own phone
with any mobile plan and you keep your
same phone number along with all your
contacts and if you're not 100 satisfied
mim mobile has you covered with the
seven day money back guarantee you've
been using it right it usually works
with your phone it's fine right you get
good service same thing same exact thing
for fifteen dollars instead of a hundred
and fricking twenty five dollars switch
to mint mobile and get premium wireless
service starting it starting at just 15
bucks to get your new wireless plan for
just those 15 bucks a month and get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mint mobile.com
hey bam
that's mintmobile.com
i just try to mix it up to make it fun
so i lower and raise my voice so the
people watching just feel like i'm
putting in a little effort because we
all want to be here get your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
minmobile.com hey babe those are you
guys who do it tell me in the comments
because i want to know what your
experience is like this might be the way
of the future guys i am constantly
looking for ways to cut expenses i now
have about 100 streaming services plus
cable i do not need them anymore i want
to cut that cord uh so when i ended up
when i pay on top of what i paid for all
the services
i was my balls were blown off i had no
more testicles after that
okay i want to trim my tv in streaming
budget but that would mean giving up a
bunch of shows this is where philo comes
in they're a new sponsor with us philo
was created by tv lovers for tv lovers
and here's what you get for just 25
bucks a month
60 premium television channels
massive on-demand library of all your
beloved shows all the movies all the top
tier stuff to watch anytime you want
unlimited dvr which is the best and
biggest in the industry i guess that
nobody else beats that dvr amount um
let's just save all your shows for up to
one full year you could stream filo on
up to three devices at the exact same
time it's super easy to use with no
hassles and no contracts man these
people are really doing stuff with
innovation okay add up what you're
paying right now it's brutal philo gives
you a better television experience for
cheaper uh
i asked my friends at philo if i could
offer you guys a special deal to try
philo and they told me of course they
said who is this i said it's sal they
said salud i said volcano they said it
still doesn't ring a bell i said hey
babe they said not yet i said taste buds
i said not yet i said misery index they
said not yet i said in practical jokers
they said i think
so
i got you guys 25 off your first two
months go to philo dot tv slash hey babe
that's philo dot tv
slash hey babe i'm doing it you should
do it we got look at that boom
can you put a smoke effect
chris had to run pick up his kids from
school we had a hot tag if you watch
wrestling a hot tag as you got the baby
boy joey d hey joey roses came in hot
because we're filming an episode of
taste buds next and hey by the way if
you're a hay babe fan and you don't
watch taste buds what gives with that
we're curious the way i feel is every
taste buds person should be watching hey
babe and every hay bay person should be
watching taste buds yeah yeah i'd like
to see i'd like to see even numbers
every week exactly the same thing it's a
different dynamic it's different it's
different fun we we uh we food battle
and now we battle about anything really
yeah yeah but you know we have fun this
is became a little no it's a little no
pressure network love here it is yeah
you're going to round out this episode
so what happened so chris had to split
chris had to pick up the kids pick up
the kids and we were just running a
little short and so we were like oh
joey's coming right in why don't we do a
uh a guest a little guest dropping so
you're actually i think you are well you
did hey babe already without me yes oh
so
you might be our first ever like well
you're not really a guest your co-host
yeah now i'm co-hosting with you yeah so
sal and joe present hey babe yeah
and you know when uh when they hosted
together you and chris you kind of
bashed out a little bit so maybe you
guys should trash chris a little bit
here really i mean it's look i don't
have an instagram series
uh called the stefano for nothing which
by the way
yeah sound off right now you gotta tell
them
just
i mean take the floor
i want to congratulate chris uh
and modern medical science
for his pitch at the mets game
because they somehow taught a barnyard
pig how to throw a baseball
which i never thought i'd see this in my
lifetime yeah i've seen him clone a
sheep and now i saw a pig throw a ball i
think he threw a strike here well a week
before the brooklyn cyclone game he
threw it right into the floor yeah and
then later he you saw he gave it that
rainbow oh my god he was so nervous they
had us in like a green room he was just
eating every everything they were
serving
this was the good spread in the
greenhouse holy [ __ ] yeah i've never
been treated that nice pimp i like your
fit today oh yeah yeah thank you i've
been meaning to tell you and i keep
forgetting first of all the color of
your shirt is in my top three favorite
colors of all time
it's like a mustard like a mustard type
brown
i just love that i love that now but i
cannot believe you noah curse has
brought up pimps slacks today i have
seen these
cotton these are jeans with sunflowers
printed on them
so pimp is wearing
white
dungarees
with sunflowers so like all over them
not sewn in though they're they're in
the they're they're in the material
they're printed on somehow they're
printed on there where did you purchase
those make sense that makes a lot of
sense
where do you buy something like that
pip's got a perfect color scheme going
on the match is popping your color story
is stupendous yeah you even have a peach
peach and yellow sock
socks on here tie dye socks peach and
yellowish beige and the only reason i
didn't sorry my nose inches the only
reason i didn't point out these pants is
because i'm already familiar with these
pants
because
when you get you and chris were flying
to la
he sent me from the plane
a picture of you and these pants
uh
yeah tsa hated me in these pants yeah
oh they were just like cut the dog
he's got so much drugs
he yeah he was like texting me like pimp
showed up in sunflower pass
it is vibrant though thanks man i love
to just dress in outfits that will annoy
chris to his core i know he gets annoyed
that's so it's so funny because he
wouldn't be caught dead
in anything remotely close to what you
wear yet a lot of what you wear reminds
me of what i used to wear like that
shirt without a doubt i would have had
that shirt it also looks like a little
throwback with the you know it looks
like a little vintage thing but um it's
so funny because then you and chris
travel together a lot and it's so funny
you just saddled up next to him and your
purple glasses and your son and your big
freaking chords and everything yeah when
we're in baltimore on stage you called
me willy wonka yeah because chris said
rightfully so he was in corduroy on
corduroy wow that's why and then chris
is wearing like
a starter sweatshirt yeah he's doing on
stage in sweatpants oh god remember the
side felt
the the that's chris now that's the
universal seinfeld episode where george
starts wearing sweatpants and uh oh i
would drape myself a velvet if it was
socially acceptable but goes he goes do
you know the message you're sending to
the world when you wear these pants
i've given up
chris chris is the person that i know in
my life that
he might be the only one that i know in
my life that consistently has on a
sports jersey
you know i like jerseys but i i can't
pull them off in that way it's chris
i would say the three jersey awareness
people
chris i know okerson quite frequently oh
he does football once he's football
jersey no but chris wears like
everything from baseball to football no
maybe not no baseball football uh hockey
jerseys he wears and he even wears uh
does he wear any any yeah he does he has
does he have nba stuff
i believe so i can't keep i believe i've
seen him in the summertime wearing an
nba jersey
but but like there are certain people i
know that never don't have some kind of
sports insignia on their body
but chris is one verzi's one
uh nate berghatzi bergatzi
uh okra yeah uh you're wearing a
phillies cap i never hear you talk
sports are you no sports is that just a
black on black representing the hometown
it's representing the hometown but you
don't do sports right i don't do sports
at all no but i do i never have some i
wear a couple sports hats to represent
mainly philly sure sure and this is the
this is the classic like chuck d p e
black course of course you don't do
sports like that in that way no never no
i mean i i'll go to games just to hang
out and stuff you know i went to the
yankees game you don't follow you never
bought a jersey you're not rooting for
people come play off when i was a kid i
had the starter i liked the bulls when i
was a kid a lot i had to start a bulls
jacket i had to start a raiders jacket
because i liked nwa uh
and then i had now nwa what does that
stand for
not what
i'm allowed to say
uh now the uh
but yeah past that that was kind of it
for me uh i've been wearing detroit
tiger's head since i was a little kid
because my dad bought me one
when he was on a business trip to
detroit when i was a kid he brought me
back a detroit tiger sat and he goes he
goes this is from detroit it says d like
derosa
so i always
that's all it took right yeah that's
funny that he stuck with me for my whole
life the reason i'm a pittsburgh
steelers fan yeah my dad didn't really
watch sports at all if anything we could
we would connect on like boxing or like
late 90s early 2000 yankees when they
were so accessible to everyone and
winning and playoffs were fun other than
that no right so one day he takes me to
go clothes shopping and when you do a
clothes shop and as a kid you buy like
everything like you go for that summer
or that winter and they and then you're
in the dressing room all day and your
parents just go try on try it on try it
on anyway so uh just i guess arbitrarily
uh
steelers gear we went we went to go
shopping and steelers were a dynasty
when we were younger and that their
their merch was available everywhere and
he he just picked all the steelers stuff
and i tried it on and that was my
clothes for the year and i was like no
joke i was probably like seven
i love it and i just was like all right
so i got steelers on my team i love it i
uh i feel like i could get into hockey
oh man i feel like i should hockey i
could get into because
video game i enjoy playing
uh
and
i it's the it's the only game i enjoy
have you really watched
have you never been to a live hockey i
have and i loved it i loved it but my
point is is like i could watch hockey on
tv and enjoy it even when i go to a live
baseball game or a live football game or
whatever
it's not that i'm not into it at all i
get excited when the team almost wins
like i'll sometimes i'll go watch sunday
football with with oakerson to watch the
eagles play yeah
but like there's something with a hockey
where hockey draws me in the way that
like boxing does where i'm like i'm not
into it but like when i'm watching it
i'm like i'm like well you know playoff
hockey is a whole nother beast
playoff hockey is like every possession
of the puck is like people are just like
oh my god you know what i mean it's like
you're only gonna
playoff hockey is the most intense thing
you'll ever watch yeah i love it i love
it
they gotta slow down now when does it
happen did you start uh
well the new yeah right now right isn't
it
presease yeah oh okay so we're just
ramping up so why don't we go to some
rangers game
there might be it might have started or
it starts very very very very soon why
don't we go to some rangers games well
cause i'm an islander fan
all right do they play here they are at
the new ubs arena which we are going to
be playing you're saying a lot of stuff
that i don't understand there's a new
arena in long island and it's opening up
uh in the next month or a month and we
are we're on the docket to play it uh
might be pushed a little bit why don't
we why don't we go to some rangers games
at madison square yeah because i'm an
islanders fan that's what i was you so
you won't go to a rangers game i'll go
when they play the islanders
wow but you won't just go and hang out
with me at a rangers game
it's like the ranges
new york rangers no it's not the rangers
why i won't go
what is it it's me
you
what would you do if you didn't have
high interest loans or credit card debt
with upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily start
living your life
if you're carrying debt if you dread
looking at your credit card statements
you're not alone the weight of debt
could be crippling i was there i
remember it took me three years well
three years to pay off my credit cards
and a decade to pay off my student loans
but now i am debt free
uh rather than looking at a credit score
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income your current employment
and credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in minutes for loans between a thousand
and fifty thousand dollars uh find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you we want
to know they want to know that you're
listening
from us and then they appreciate us and
and we go round and round loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application guys
it's upstart.com
hey babe check it out
no i'm saying i gotta hook up with the
devils too they're they're we're friends
with them so we can go any devil's games
we want
so we all know you're famous
i'm asking you as a friend do you want
to
do you want to go sometime to a rangers
game i've had a hook up at
these places my whole life it's just
family you know it's no no it's fine
you love to do that to me you love to
make you believe that i am some rich
famous person would you not go to a
rangers game with me what are you
looking at here what are you doing
there's a [ __ ] hole in my swag oh
yeah well then there there that's
before you got on here derosa we were
talking about uh ghost experiences have
you ever had a ghost run in
i
i do have a story oh oh oh oh oh oh i
can't wait to hear it i do it but hold
on a second
i want to hear how you interact with i
think you interact with a ghost the same
way you interact with everybody else in
your life you probably made a ghost roll
if you see through eyes
[Music]
i'll go to a ranger's game 100 100
i love the garden you know i played it
it's sold out yeah yeah rich yeah i'm
famous
i feel like these shows are slowly
becoming you two negotiating your social
life
i mean what are we talking to speak like
this he showed a hole in his sweatshirt
which was the equivalent of when like
scrooge on christmas morning was like
i'm one of you now
no i'm trying to relate cause all your
pants always have holes in them
no
i uh
he loves he loves to give me that little
ribbon because i'm richard i'm the least
i am because it bothers you it's funny i
know
jay taylor i'm a relatable clown jay
taught me that
that it bothers me yeah jay did not jay
doesn't come at me like that
jay all the time makes jokes about your
money and stuff no he doesn't
to you and it makes you them
he does and it makes you uncomfortable
and he said to me he goes i love like
watch like i love how uncomfortable
shall get so i make jokes about his
money yeah because he knows that i yeah
he's fine i don't really recall him
making too many of those jokes like i
recall you doing that well because ours
are mine are documented on a podcast you
know yeah he says to you you know in the
kitchen yeah yeah yeah yeah
well i don't
please don't don't put me in that bucket
i'm gonna keep saying it
i'm a man
what what are you uh
i'm a man of the people i'm on you're
just twisting the knife in his forehead
let's stop it now
i'm like i'm on basic cable
that's just everyone pipe it down
i i'm not extremely in basic cable i
can't afford basically
folks uh i have no i have no bling cue
also my car is from 2011 i love it to
pieces q also gets a big kick out of it
he thinks it's very funny cue yeah we
were talking about this like right in
front of you but you didn't hear i guess
everyone knows how much it bothered me
he was like he was like what were you
saying about him living up on a silver
cloud or something that's like yeah and
i was telling him he was like he's
laughing his balls off he's like that's
really funny man
i'm i'm frugal you are generous you're
very generous
very nice because i worked in that
industry but i also i'm uh
you know i'm shrewd with my money you're
very you're very responsible your money
which i will lean on at some point when
i'm uh
[Laughter]
my
destitute
you know at least he's transparent
my decisions my decisions will lead me
eventually to an alleyway
and i'll be calling you at that time
let's talk about how you made a ghost
try to kill themselves for a second time
by the way
i think derose would be the perfect
candidate for future ghosts oh yeah oh
god you in ghost form
everlasting just like
complaints complaints um
oh that's great
that's great
wait a minute is that a sitcom it might
be a sicker
joe's when joe's a ghost he's not boo
he's boo
he says it differently
listen it's the ghost of the rosa
[Applause]
[Music]
coming to fxx
it fall 19 or two that whatever you
would haunt like an italian restaurant
mommy mommy there's a ghost in my room
scaring me with negativity
i started crying and it told me to shut
up
told me to grow up
why is the whiskey bottle always uh
are you drinking in the house no i swear
it wasn't me
holy [ __ ] oh my god all right
all right i'll tell you my ghost story
uh
true story true story i was up in um
i believe it was buffalo
doing helium in buffalo
and i was staying in a a hotel they put
you in a very nice hotel there but it's
it's a historic hotel it's
it's it's it's been updated it's not
like you're staying in a room that looks
old but but these are big airy rooms
with like high ceilings there's a
fireplace in the middle of the room this
is like the standard room it's not like
you're in a suite it's just like no i'm
sure you had i'm sure you splurged and
spent a lot of money on your hotel room
yeah high ceilings fireplace in the
middle standard stuff
no i'm saying like this that's not how
it sounds like the rooms i stay in joe
that's how i met them
i mean like the rooms in this place like
they have like they're these big rooms
i've been in plenty of those historic
places it's like an old hotel
so and you see how how well they used to
treat people for their money back you
know in the day you know but anyway um
so i'm in buffalo right so i'm staying
there it's the first night and i'm i'm
sleeping there i'm trying to sleep i
can't sleep
i think i was going through a breakup at
the time i had a lot on my mind but um i
was uh
very uh keen
to
the idea that there was like a presence
or something in the room it just seemed
like there was something in the room and
it was freaking me out and i couldn't
sleep
and i was like
this is ridiculous you're being crazy
it's just because it's a huge room
sometimes you even talk to yourself out
loud i do that yeah
you're in a huge room you're going
through an emotional there's no ghost in
the room
i'm just like
i feel like something's in here but i've
never felt like that i don't scare very
easily with stuff like that
you know i'm a big horror fan like it
just i was like this is weird i've never
experienced this before
something unsettling exactly
so then the next day
i wake up and i go downstairs to the to
the front desk and i'm going to go out
and get breakfast or whatever and i'm
looking at the you know so they have the
rack of the
things in the hotel of like the
pamphlets of where to go where to go and
then
i noticed like explore the caves or go
on a
a fan boat ride yeah and then i noticed
they have pamphlets for the hotel
history and i pick one up and the first
thing i say is
famously haunted
the hotel you're in yeah and i was like
holy [ __ ]
that's weird so
that is the extent you felt something
you it you felt uneasy you felt weird
you felt the presence you chalked it up
to whatever then the next day you
realized that you were in a haunted
hotel yeah and i didn't know that
beforehand wow that was the only time
that's ever happened to me that was the
only time i ever felt like there's
something's off like
something doesn't feel right somebody's
in here
i have one scary experience which i've
already told on this pod but i felt like
a ghost squeeze my hand
or something squeezed my hand or i felt
my hand being squeezed i attributed in
my old my own place
like but what happened i was i was went
to lay down to go to bed and i just had
just had lay down to go to bed the
television was still on
with no sound
and my door was closed to my bedroom and
then i heard someone's talking wasn't
the television just heard like someone
talking like i thought they were talking
downstairs or something and then i just
heard someone kind of walking
and uh
and in my head i was just like oh it's
just them downstairs but then i felt
them
i kind of felt them like
above me but i was under the blanket
like this i told this story
and then i just my hand was out of the
blanket because i was like laying like
this and i just felt someone
grab my hand and hold it and then i
didn't move because i was like holy [ __ ]
someone is in my home and then they
squeezed it tighter
and i felt them squeezing my like my
fingers like that
and i just was like it's not a ghost i'm
definitely awake i was like am i
dreaming no i'm awake i took complete
inventory i was like i am literally
awake right now my hand is literally
being squeezed right now what are the
explanations i did this all in like five
sec ten seconds i'm like it's is it a
spirit squeezing me probably not did
someone break into my house i don't know
but there's someone so i knew that i was
i couldn't lay there i just felt too
vulnerable so i was like i have to fight
for my life and so i i counted like
three i swear to you and i just
jumped up out of my bed and was ready to
just
fight to my death i was gonna i know i
had a little one of those little
souvenir bats in my closet from yankee
stadium i was gonna try to grab that and
when i just jumped up and jumped out
nobody there nobody in my room but i
heard someone speak i heard someone walk
and i heard and i felt someone squeezing
my hand i was awake so i really don't
know what it was jesus god man i mean
the only reason i believe in ghosts is
when i became a real estate agent it was
part of the exam i had her memorize if
the house was haunted i could get sued
get out of here yeah get out of here
oh the government acknowledges this yeah
did chris told me about something about
the amityville people or something like
that one time
the amityville harbor yeah yeah yeah the
house that's definitely haunted yeah i
mean no no no no it's not that was all
scam they came out yeah yeah that that's
been revealed that it was all really i
don't know i feel like anywhere there's
no the defeo thing happened the guy
killed his family that happened in the
house
the whole thing is complete [ __ ] it
came out like they they eventually came
clean and said what's the scariest
horror movie you've ever seen the
exorcist yeah that was up there
especially when it came out
like i can't imagine yeah
later
all that stuff has been proven
fraudulent though like every one of the
cases of not the ex i mean i don't know
about the exercise because that is based
on what's
allegedly a real case but all that stuff
like um the the warrens you know that
the uh uh
with the conjuring the that couple they
were the amityville investigators like
all of their major cases people came out
later and they were like they told us to
say this so because they would they said
it would make headlines
but like no one has ever really had any
proof of a ghost ever ever
why is it in the real estate exam
i know but if you watch all these these
ghost hunter shows
all produced they never come out with
anything no one's ever really gotten
anything on but to counter point that we
talked to brendan schaub on chrissy
chaos who was on the biggest go show as
a guest okay investigator and he said he
was scared shitless i don't doubt he's
scared i don't doubt that he doesn't
know what really to believe but he's
talking about a man that's been hit in
the head more times than i mean god
knows what he's
he might have saw mayor mccheese in that
house
you bring up mcdonald's i know i don't
know
you bring up if you speak for three
minutes you're mentioning a mcdonald's
reference it's it's actually insane
it is as it was coming out of my mouth i
was like why did i pick that
um
i uh yeah but there's no i mean come on
look there's no one ever has an
experience in broad daylight i'm never
at an intersection and and
and see a ghost oh it was a kid in a hat
looked like he was from the victorian
era well i saw him at the i saw him on
hollywood and vine
doesn't happen oh you know what all the
doors from the building swung open and
slammed closed three times it was the
building over on front street no it
never happens it's always in your house
when you're alone at night it's all it's
all in our head man
i mean i don't know i'm not saying i
don't believe in it i've heard some
pretty
convincing uh accounts on you know
documentaries and things like that
and you know i don't know maybe they
don't catch it on camera because
they're a little too hip to to to get
themselves caught on camera i don't know
but uh but think about it i think
there's a great chance that it's just
inter-dimensional crossovers
interdimensional planetary i don't
disagree
some
interdimension if there's some alien
[ __ ] going on this that maybe i believe
in other life forms but just think just
pull back a little bit and look at it as
a whole there's
there's just roving
spirits stuck here
and and they're
they're haunting us
yeah
like let's say spirits did exist why
aren't they just going about their own
business they're tortured souls it reeks
of uh prose
you understand like i i don't i don't i
don't necessarily
understand the motivation i think the
narrative is [ __ ] but like the human
eye and ear can only hear a spectrum and
see a spectrum yeah so maybe it's just
another animal that lives on the other
side of that
yeah so you think there's
interdimensional [ __ ] going on that's
what i would guess that it is
that's what i would guess that it is you
know one day a lot of this stuff's going
to be revealed it'll be way past our
time but we you know we have a lot of
theories and we're chipping away and
some things get revealed but there's
gonna be a day on this earth
whenever it is where things are just
common knowledge i mean think about what
they didn't know
x and how exponentially how much
information we we achieve and accumulate
and get saturated with and that's only
going to continue the rate at which we
will learn and understand things is
going to
exponentially increase so
you know from 1900 to 2000 versus from
twenty two hundred to twenty three
hundred i mean
that's going to be a real scene hanging
out around there if we have children and
they have children they have children
and they'll they'll know wow their
podcasts are gonna suck
well yeah i mean
eventually what are you talking about
because there's nothing it's all been
revealed right when do podcasts take a
hot [ __ ] five years but five years yeah
what's the new new it'll probably be the
same exact thing it'll just be like what
we did to radio
it was podcasting right
yeah it'll be like some new app on your
phone where you message the episode
directly to certain people or some
[ __ ] i don't know
well let's continue to do this while we
can yeah is that the end yeah
come to joey roses we're opening very
soon uh end of october hopefully early
november uh joe derosa comedy on
instagram and twitter follow me please
watch taste buds yes yes watch taste
buds and october 29th comes to us in
durham
be a um don't be a flake don't run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe hey babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey